[Music]
if monster hunter world is your first
monster hunter you may be wondering how
to capture a monster fortunately despite
all the dense tutorials and steep
learning curve it's not as tough as it
may seem
first you'll need a shock trap and a few
tranq bombs you can craft the shock trap
with a thunder bug and a trap tool you
can only carry one with you at a time so
don't worry about crafting a bunch of
these and to craft tranq bombs you'll
need a sleep herb and a parish room the
good news is that if you're doing a
capture quest both these items will be
available for you in the box at the
start of the quest once you've stocked
up on equipment you will need to track
the monster like any other hunt it's
important to note that you don't need to
do a capture quest in order to catch a
monster but you will need to craft your
own equipment fight the monster until it
starts limping and then set a shock trap
you can only carry one trap at a time so
make sure to place it carefully if the
monster runs off to take a nap you can
set it next to it and it should trigger
automatically after its stun throw down
a couple tranq bombs and you're done the
benefit of capturing a monster is
opposed to killing it is that you get
more monster parts at the end of the
quest you won't be able to skin it but
if you're having trouble finding a
certain part this should improve your
odds
if you're playing monster hunter world
and you have any questions feel free to
hit me up on Twitter or leave a comment
below and I'll try to help out thank you
for watching